Hello?
Ayyyyy Um...
Hellooo I just started my stream We're live Bro, everyone thought we were waiting People were like, oh we must be waiting for Doki She's the one that's late No, it was Brawl Pro that requested the stream To be pushed up 30 minutes And then...
So that's why I was...
Cause I was talking to my stream I was like, okay I can't... I'm not home right now And they're like, well I can't believe Doki's playing Brawl Pro For the reason why the stream was pushed back But it was because Brawl Pro pushed back the stream That I went outside to get errands done Because I had an extra 30 minutes That's why I wasn't home Cause this guy needs to eat Even though he doesn't want to eat on stream
You could've eaten on stream Yeah, I'm listening I'm listening What do you mean you don't remember it?
How is... What do you mean?
He won't add you What do you mean you don't remember that?
Like, is that a threat?
No, it's not a threat It's like, okay, maybe I just eat on stream from now on The way you said that sounded like a threat Yeah, I'll remember I went and sabotaged He's gonna remember You don't even know how to play the game You're like, we gotta do a practice run before we play Where the fuck does practice...
What do you mean we gotta do a practice run?
Okay, let me...
They're saying you're a bit quiet Let me fix the audio real quick You were like mad loud, I had to turn you all the way down Oh shit, sorry Yeah, my game volume was low Wait, so you've never played...
You haven't played it, right?
So you don't really know the controls, right?
Uh, me and Matt played it yesterday Cody hasn't played it Oh, okay, okay, good I played it already Oh, there's Cody There he is Oh my god Oh my god, it's gaming time?
You guys can change your color, by the way, if you want to So we don't get mixed up Yeah, it's in change color Oh, I like how you both chose red You guys both chose red anyway Can we pick a character that's similar, please?
No, just pick my character, okay?
That's cool Guys, guys!
Why don't you guys be red?
No way we have the same favorite color!
You guys both picked green That's beautiful!
Oh my god, you're all matching How about you guys tell what color you want before we go change it?
Well, no one picked my color Me and Matt are alright, we both have the right colors I have been set in stone, you know Hey, can I invite Void?
Can Void play?
Yeah, yeah Yeah, I like him.
We did a Rivals thing together Another fellow Magneto player There he is Why is it Void?
Hello Hello Another Magneto guy Hello Are we just gonna start?
Whatever, I guess I'm the host, right?
Yeah, you are the host Yeah, no, that's fine.
You don't need to You don't need it Yeah, you don't need it No, you don't None of you guys need it It's just lethal Do you believe Brawl Pros never play lethal content?
That's crazy I mean, he's a controller player Okay, okay, wait, Kony, Kony, I'll teach you something Okay, press Q Kony, press Q Alright, let's go, let's go Start the game, start the game What are you doing?
What are you doing?
I'm a baby Am I a baby?
Are you a baby?
Tell me, how do I get in the big mode?
What's happening?
You're forever baby mode, welcome to the game Welcome to the game, Kony Yes Who's a little baby?
That's you Who's a little baby?
Get out Appies Appies I'm a big boy
Get away Welcome to the game Am I a monster?
Are you kidding me?
He turned into a monster, Kony got burgered He got burgered He's dead already?
No, he got sandwiched Get out You're stupid Get out You'll get better soon Can you help me?
Get away from me You're good now He's okay now
I like how Void is actually working I'm a working man He's a working man Clocking in I gotta stop hitting Q Don't hit Q He's coming back He's coming back for you He's coming back He's coming back Appie No, I'm not Appie Okay, okay Do you want Appies?
Who is this?
Oh, there's a clown There's a clown?
Is he dangerous?
He's very dangerous Why do they have the clown already?
This is level 1 I can't believe it It's only level 1 We got clown already I think we have enough, right?
Yeah, we have enough We can make more money Are we done?
Are we done?
I'm pushing the cart back It's one shot I'm pushing the cart back It's one shot I don't know how to close doors Just hold left click I'm putting in stuff here Because he can destroy the items Are they dead?
I think they all died Okay
Okay Goodbye
Wait, you guys came back Wait, you're alive?
Wait, Kony You're alive Wait, how did you live?
Magic, I'm a magician Okay, goodbye guys
What?
I don't think they know
Goodbye Why is the cart not going?
Why is the cart not going?
Wait
Why isn't it starting?
I don't understand It's supposed to start
Only half of the door Oh my god, you guys are alive Yeah, it was crazy I got blasted by a laser
Wait, what are we waiting for?
I'll gather everyone, hold on Alright, cool, I'll stay here I did my job I think it bugged out They were supposed to be dead by now
Yeah, it got bugged Oh, we're gonna be stuck in this level
How is the cart?
Can we do it?
Wait, did Kony die again?
No, no, no, we're fine Oh, there we go, we did it I'm back, I'm back, let's go We did it We did it Yay Turn on the engine I did my job You actually really did Yippee I still don't know how to play the game Don't worry Don't worry
Uppies Uppies Uppies
I'm going to buy a health upgrade.
We need to buy... uh... wait, where's the strength?
Okay, who wants to be our... who wants to be our HM slave?
Who wants to be the... who wants to be the HM Pokemon slave?
Who wants to be that?
Yeah, who... it's KonyKony, yeah.
Alright.
Don't worry, Kony.
You're going to be our main HM guy.
We're putting it all on you.
Get all the upgrades.
It'll make sense.
Don't worry, KonyMeister.
It'll make so much sense.
You're going to be my Bidoof, Kony.
Kony, you're going to be the Bidoof.
Yeah, you're going to be a Bidoof.
We're going to give you so many shots.
Enhancements.
Yes!
Kony, you want to take me for a ride here?
Kony, now you know what I was doing, Kony.
Alright, Kony.
Kony, wait, wait, wait.
He's our Bidoof.
Kony, take these upgrades.
I'm going to put them in the juice.
Kony, take these upgrades, Kony.
Wait, who took...
Okay, you're going to be our little HM Bidoof.
Okay, power me up, please.
Oh, did I accidentally take one of those?
Yeah, you took it.
Wait, which one did you take?
Maliciously takes one all, but that was a mistake, though.
I was just figuring out the keyboard situation.
Alright, wait, what did you take, Brawl Pro?
Which one did you take?
Stamina?
I don't know.
Alright, Sam, where's our cart?
Oh, I found a mullet.
Oh, yeah, where is it?
Wait, did it not come with us?
Okay, Kony, if you press tab, and you see green dots, those are the things that we're... those are the treasures.
Oh, okay.
When we put them in the cart.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's our lethal quota.
Okay, now we have two, but some of the items don't show up.
Yeah.
Open the refrigerator.
Whoops.
It's okay.
Also, I brought up the volume a little bit, Chad.
Let me know if it's better.
Alright, I'm going to break this plate.
Watch this.
Oh, I did it.
It doesn't break if you throw it in the thing.
No, it does.
It does if you throw it too hard.
Alright, is there anything in the toilet?
No, it's not even... there's not even water in the toilet.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, it's a 1,900.
Yeah, that's a... this is a big boy.
It's a big boy.
I got a big boy.
Wait, we already have enough for one.
We should put this back.
I'm pushing.
Where is it?
Beep, beep.
Stay in the shopping cart.
I don't know if I want to.
Should I?
Stay in there.
You'll be safe.
No, it'll res you.
It'll res you.
I'll trust me.
I'll be resurrected twice.
I'm going to heaven.
Do you think he went to heaven?
There, see?
What's heaven?
I actually lived twice.
I can't believe it.
Yes, see?
I told you.
I can't believe... man, you didn't believe me?
I can't believe you didn't believe me after everything we've been through.
I know, it was...
How could you?
I'll go in the cart, my bad.
Alright, get in the cart, child.
It's Costco time.
Ow!
I can't do it.
It's Costco time.
Are you ready for the free samples?
Oh, dude, I love Costco free samples.
Okay, where did he go?
Whenever you actually go... when was the last time you went outside?
Hello?
Is this somebody's head?
Oh my god, there's a giant spider in his skull!
Oh my god.
You can't get me.
Get out of there.
I hope the head gets you.
I hope the head gets you, guys.
I hope it gets you.
I was gonna feed you to the head.
You know, yeah?
Ah!
Wait, it's Trash Importer.
Coney!
Coney, there's a duck, Coney!
I hope he touches the duck.
Hey, Void, help!
Help me carry this!
It's 11k here!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
It's 11k right here!
Guys, I think they're dead.
They're awfully quiet.
I don't think they're alive anymore.
Why are they so quiet?
I'm pretty sure they're dead, guys.
I think they're dead.
I think they were, like, laughing about the head, and then now I don't hear them anymore.
So I think the head got... okay.
Wait, there's a guy!
11k here!
Void!
Pick it up!
Where's our inch head?
Where's our Bidoof?
Get the Bidoof over here!
Don't touch the duck, though.
No, the duck's worth 20k.
I checked earlier.
Oh, I don't think so.
Nice try!
He told me all about this silly duck!
Oh my god, is that even possible?
Oh no, we have to get rid of the money.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, we'll put the money out.
I'll hold the money.
Hold the 5k.
What's the worst that could happen?
Alright, I'm gonna grab this.
I'm putting the 5k here.
Wait, where is it?
Is it up here?
Oh, it's up here.
What the fuck, there's stairs now?
Wait, wait, wait.
Guys, my chat is begging me to click the duck.
I'm not gonna do it.
That is very clearly not... he is so desperate for attention.
I'm not doing it.
There's clearly something up there.
This is a 6 player game, right?
Dude, we could play with the duck.
Isn't that right, duck?
Yeah, click the duck!
Oh my god!
I'm alive, let's get out of here.
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit!
I made a big mistake!
Surely there's no monsters here.
Dude, guys, look at the duck.
Isn't the duck so cute?
He's so cute, right?
I'm outta here.
Oh, goodbye.
I'm assuming he died.
I'll get his head, don't worry.
Oh, I made a mistake.
I clicked the duck.
I thought the duck would attack everybody.
Whoops.
Doki, where are you?
Oh, I got the duck following me.
Oh, thank god!
Thank you.
What a hero.
I wanna click this so bad.
What if I just click it?
You're gonna be a hero.
Alright, I'll count down to ten.
If nobody comes back, we leave.
Oh my god, you're back.
Wait, did Coney die?
Okay.
No, no, you see here?
When we're rezzed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Matt's a goner.
No, he's dead.
He's been dead for a while now.
Really?
We'll figure it out if you press this.
We'll figure it out who's alive.
How long do we wait for it?
Oh, oh, oh, there's somebody.
You made it.
Oh, you made it!
Hey, so Coney's totally dead.
I was trying to grab his head, but the skull is gatekeeping.
Yeah, and Void wants to be a hero.
Should we give him a timer?
Let's give him a timer.
Oh my god!
Alright.
Alright, here we go, Void.
I believe in you!
You got this, Void!
You can be the hero you've always wanted to be!
That is not gonna happen.
I'm just gonna say you told me to do it.
You said, yeah.
I said, do we give him a timer?
I'll own up to it.
Yeah, it was all on me.
I said, do we give him a timer?
You said, yes.
Get Coney's head!
What happened?
Where's Void?
What do you mean?
He's right here!
It's right here!
Oh, you made it, Void!
Hey, everybody!
Get Coney's head!
Alright, Coney, we got you more HMs!
Yes, please!
Yum, yum, yum!
Feed him all the HMs, guys!
Void's eyes turned red and I got scared!
I don't know what happened there!
That was crazy!
We have a lot more money!
Okay, how do I...
Do I bring up Matt's voice a bit?
Okay.
If you want...
No, you do not!
I just died!
I deserve a nice treat!
I have seen the afterlife!
What did you see?
God told me I needed that!
What are you gonna do?
What can you kill?
What can you kill with that?
Well, we'll have to see!
We'll get rid of this.
Can we kill those those little floating thingies with the hammers?
What?
The ones that spin?
No!
It'll be fine!
My hammer!
No, keep it on here!
Keep it on here!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I thought I was gonna get crushed!
Alright, let's move.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it jumps!
Okay, we got the hammer!
Alright, let's go.
Wait, we did?
I'll take it to the cart!
Wait, why are you destroying this place with it?
Here we go!
Oh boy!
I hope we paid for this!
We did!
Alright, Kony!
Get ready!
Eat your vegetables!
Where's my hammer?
Kony, eat your vegetables, Kony!
I have a feeling Doggy Bird might have lied.
Eat your vegetables!
So you can grow big and strong!
I'm ready to go!
As an HM slave, what's Kony doing for us?
He can basically pick things up stronger.
Because he's stronger.
Oh, you have some health, friends.
Yeah, he'll be the hero.
I don't know why.
Get Kony's head!
I got you, boy!
Oh, this is the shotgun guy!
Here, I got you a little juice.
I worked very hard for this HP.
Okay, so this guy is the shotgun guy.
Oh, wait, look at that!
This is what that is!
See, I told you!
Our Bidoof is doing it!
Oh my god.
Okay, no game.
Okay, guys, we got...
It's right here, just put it inside.
Just put it inside.
That works too.
There we go, look at that.
Good job, Bidoof.
Kony is strongest of all.
We found monkey too.
There's like something here.
Man, I heard some screaming coming from that door you just walked through.
Really?
Yeah.
Left or right.
What is the function of this staircase?
There's nothing up here.
Maybe, maybe to avoid monsters.
That's what it has to do.
Oh, I'm rotating.
Guys, I can't stop rotating.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Where's the cart?
Follow my voice.
I'm bringing it closer.
You're destroying it.
Let go, let go, let go.
I said let go!
Oh my god!
Minus $7,000.
It's not that easy!
It's not...
Oh no!
Is that a baby?
Dude, you're in the way of the door!
I'm trying...
Why are we always minus a billion dollars?
What's happening here?
Where did the baby go?
There's a monkey chasing us.
Yahoo!
Yes.
Is he still there?
Why don't you have it?
No, I did!
I thought we bought it.
Oh my god.
That guy was scary.
Are people still alive?
Dude, why did you let go of the music box?
I did!
The instructions were very unclear.
No, no, no.
You had very unclear instructions.
You had a five second...
I played ping!
It was ping.
You didn't account for my ping when you called it.
I had a five second delay.
Oh, okay.
I have 100 ms.
I believe that.
Whenever Kony says what is that thing, I don't...
No!
Wait, where's Tony?
I'm scared.
You had a good look at it there.
Where's your car?
Oh, he sees it now.
We have to put this in the car.
If you don't put this in the car, it's gonna go...
Wait, did you hear that?
Yeah, I think that was the cucumber monster they saw.
Wait, what's the cucumber...
What's that?
What is that?
I think two of us are dead.
What was that?
I never heard of that.
It's a cucumber.
Oh, do we...
I don't think we're gonna make it past level two.
Level three?
Guys,
I'm afraid.
Wait!
He's breaking everything.
He's breaking all our stuff!
What a dick!
Stop it!
Why is he breaking everything?
He just doesn't like us.
Oh no, I got...
Okay, I'm rotating.
Help!
This might not be a good time to be rotating, Cone.
Oh no, he's still there.
Why won't he leave?
He's a tough one.
Oh my god!
I'm scared.
I mean, I was scared.
I was scared.
I did my signatures.
Oh, Cone is dead.
Cone is dead.
Hey, Cone is dead.
Do you have stuff?
Guys, I got bad news.
Did everything break?
This ghost guy showed up and destroyed us.
Oh my god.
It only has a thousand.
I don't think we're gonna win this round.
No, no, no, we can.
We can clutch.
I don't think we have enough, guys.
Is there anything here?
We need like 20k.
Oh no, it's another one.
Guys, I need you guys to tell me when to drop it.
Oh my god.
Wait a second.
I'm struggling on my own.
I have another one too.
What the fuck is that?
I don't like this game.
I don't like it.
Is it gone now?
Is it gone?
I think it's gone.
Oh my god.
No, it's the infamous clock.
Oh no, it's the fucking clock.
Oh my god.
I'm not getting the clock.
No, I am.
It's the infamous clock.
I once had to sit through 30 minutes of someone trying to get the clock and they got lost.
No, not the clock.
I have a froggy.
I mean, we're getting close to the first quota.
Wait, I mean, we already have 9k in there.
Wait, no, wait, oh.
Nevermind.
Wait, no, we got...
We have a 20k clock.
Yeah, so we gotta rez Cody.
We gotta rez him.
We should slowly push...
Oh my god.
Is that the music box?
Tell me when to drop it.
Drop it.
He's back, he's back, he's back!
He's back!
Oh my god, my money!
Yeah, I don't think we're making this.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't think we're gonna make quota.
$7,000 left.
Okay, let's just grab the TV, the TV must be it.
Yeah.
The TV.
Yeah, the TV's 7k, the TV's 7k!
We can do this!
Okay, now we push the cart back.
Okay, guys.
Guys, okay, okay, guys!
Push the cart back, push it back!
I'll go find the other extraction.
You guys push the cart.
Okay, this should be where the extraction is, right?
This seems awfully extraction-y.
Seems awfully extraction-y.
Okay.
Surely I won't die, right?
Surely I'll be safe over here if I look at the floor.
Right, guys?
If I'm just here on the floor, surely no one's gonna come over and shake me.
They can't see me, I can't see them.
I believe, I believe in them.
Okay.
Okay, we got the second point.
Nice.
Oh, bring the volume a little bit?
Yeah, I can do that.
Alright, let me know if it's better, chat.
Okay.
I'll wait here for them.
I'm a little scared.
I'm a little alone and scared right now.
Just a little guy.
I'll wait until they show up.
They'll show up, right?
Gonna show up, right?
Just a little guy, trying to make it in the big scary world.
No, that's a little too scary.
Hahaha.
That's a little too scary.
No way, I'm the only one left.
There's no way.
They'll come back for me.
Yeah?
Think it's nice and safe down this very safe hallway?
Oh, there they are.
Beep beep.
Oh, did you guys got the clock?
We got the fucking piano?
Okay, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Guys, it will be so healthy.
I'll close the door.
We thought you died.
No, no, I found the extraction point for us, remember?
Is it this way?
What's happening to the piano?
Who's rotating?
Right click is rotating, guys.
Obviously, one of you is messing with this.
Someone press right click!
Who's right clicking?
Not me, I don't do that.
Okay, someone's mouse is broken.
Who got the Razer Deathadder?
Who has that?
You mean the most highly rated gaming mouse of 2022?
I cannot believe we met Quota.
Oh my god.
It has to be in or it'll get crushed or it's gonna get crushed or it's gonna get crushed.
You should go in there and hold it.
Yeah, go make sure.
Don't worry, he gets double res.
No, he can get double res.
But he just gets one HP.
Alright, Coney, now it's dark and scary and all the monsters are more aggressive.
We're on.
Monsters?!
Oh, you can press tab.
Ouch.
I wish there was a way to defend yourself against them.
Just get high ground.
Oh, this death!
The ghost!
The thing!
Jesus.
Is it safe?
No!
I couldn't see!
Never be a hero.
I'm never gonna be a hero again.
I literally saw Void's head and I was like, maybe I'll pick him up.
Big mistake.
Should've left him.
I agree.
It's all up to Brawl Pro.
Hiding under the table.
Does Brawl Pro know that he's the only one left?
I don't think he does.
There's a chance he does.
Are the red dots the homies?
Wait, did they die?
I don't know.
He's putting it together.
He doesn't even know where to go.
He's scared for his life.
This is terrifying.
Oh god!
He can't hear any of this, right?
No.
Oh!
He's good!
Oh, he made it!
We did it.
We did it, guys.
Cause I'm the most important, obviously.
I'm the main character.
I'm literally anime.
More juices, please!
Alright, Bidoof, are you ready for more?
Yes, please.
I'm hungry.
Wait, can I have a real hammer?
Okay, yeah, yeah, you can have a real hammer.
Oh my god, it's 40!
You know you deserve it.
Go, go, go, go, go baby mode.
Oh shit, what's up there?
I'm gonna put you up there.
Go baby mode.
Oh yeah, it's cute.
Like a little baby.
No, no, this is up.
You get to go up top.
There you go, there you go, there you go.
Look, Kony, what do you see up there?
I wanna see too.
Take me up there too.
Uppies, uppies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, uppies.
And then...
No!
I'm bad at uppies.
Okay, okay, I'm ready.
I'm ready for uppies round two.
Okay, coming, coming, coming.
Uppies round two.
No!
Kony!
Open it up!
Kony, open it up!
Someone open it, someone open it.
No girls allowed.
Wow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me in!
I can't read!
I'm gonna enter anyway because I can't read.
Oh my god!
No!
What's up there?
I can't believe it.
Kony hates women.
Wait, what the fuck?
There's a dead person up here.
What is that?
Oh my god.
Alright, truce, truce, truce, truce.
I should have never shown you that.
A women's history month?
Oh my god!
A women's month too?
That's fucked.
That's the only women here.
Some enemies.
I can't believe it.
He hates women.
That is true, there is high ground in this game.
Guys, how do we save Doki?
She's dead.
How do we save Doki?
To be clear, I don't know what happened.
I can't lie!
He knew exactly what happened.
I refuse to believe.
I can't believe it.
A women's month too?
Kony, that's fucked.
That's the only women here.
No health.
$30,000 for that?
Alright Bidoof, eat your snacks.
Yummy yummy.
I am so strong.
I can't believe it.
How much HP do you have Kony?
Okay, get the big one.
Okay, never mind.
I'll get the big one too.
Oh, no, no, no, I get the big one.
No, you can't.
That's you giving.
Yeah, I have to give you.
What's your HP, Coney?
Yeah, what's your HP?
What's your HP?
Why are you...
Yeah, I was like, what are you doing?
Oh my god, wait, we have one more upgrade.
Oh, no!
Who's throwing?
Not me, though.
It wasn't...
Brofo, was it you?
Wait, wait, wait, Coney!
Coney, we have more!
Eat your, eat your, eat your veggies!
Okay, put it down.
I'll eat it.
Eat your veggies, Badoof.
Look how fast I am, ready?
Wait, wait, I need to give you HP!
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
Coney, you gotta get to use!
Coney, you gotta waste your upgrades!
Okay, what?
What happened?
I need to give you an extra.
There you go.
Oh, yeah, please.
Thank you.
Hey, what are the question marks on the map?
It means we haven't been there yet.
Oh my god, oh my god, guys!
23k!
Coney!
Get up, Badoof, here!
There's a 23k here!
The yellows.
There's another big thing, too.
Coney, Coney, we need you!
Coney, we have a 23k here.
We need you to use your strength.
There's 50k of things in here.
Use your strength, Coney.
Coney, use strength.
I will.
I'll be the strongest of all.
Use rock smash.
Is that gonna fit through the door?
Minus 1000, minus 200.
Oh, there's there's three, three extraction points.
That's scary.
Oh, I don't like this area.
This might be where the clown lives.
I think we get the clown here.
Clown man.
Clown man!
I'd probably die to the clown.
Oh!
Oh, we already got the first one.
This looks like a scary place.
Oh!
I don't like that.
I don't like this.
I don't like this area.
Oh, a soda?
That's a vending machine.
Wait, is this an extraction?
Oh, I guess we'll never know.
Oh, the music got a little scary.
A little freaky.
Wait, is that it?
Is it just one item or two items?
I think so.
Wait, it's just two items.
That's so cheap.
I don't like this.
It's getting freaky.
I don't like the freakiness.
I have a plate.
Where are the others?
Are you guys okay over there?
Jokey, jokey, you have to hide.
What is that?
Puppies!
Don't pick on me.
I can't pick you up.
Okay, I touched it.
I didn't know you could touch them.
Oh my god!
What's going on over there?
Matt, do you gotta hide maybe?
I don't know.
Who had the sledgehammer?
It's just trying to swipe at you.
Somebody had the sledgehammer!
It's like over there.
I'm just avoiding you.
Jokey will be fine.
I'm gonna look this way.
Wait.
Don't leave me, man.
Come on.
Boop.
Oh my god.
I got babied.
I am fucking Slenderman.
Oh no.
I got a loser Bidoof.
Oh my god.
Is there fall damage?
Uh, no.
Okay.
Lies to you like a boss.
I'm kidding.
There's no fall damage.
I don't remember.
Oh, there is it.
I'm scared of the doll.
Yeah, she's actually pretty scary.
It looks like someone's bringing something.
Like we're about to run into someone.
Hello?
I'm scared.
Oh!
I am strong.
Oh no.
Wait, we hit quota?
Holy.
We're gaming.
They don't know.
They don't know, guys.
If they didn't see it, it never happened.
Die, die.
Diamond.
This is the pain.
Oh god.
Guys, I have...
There's several items down here.
I need help.
I'm coming down.
I have a diamond.
Oh my god, man.
Oh my god.
Where's the last extra?
Oh!
Oh, fuck!
I'm 80 HP!
Cody, we're gonna fucking die.
Oh, that was awesome.
There was a 20,000 server thing.
Watch the merchandise.
We're gonna find the last extraction point.
We haven't found the last one.
You're right.
I don't know where it is.
Is it over there?
Yeah, we haven't gone all the way forward.
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
It's all the way here.
I found a point.
Wait, we did it.
We have enough money.
Already?
Yeah.
It's 15k.
We have 15k.
Or 22k.
Alright, we gotta get past the doll, though.
If I get the fan and push people off...
Wait, I have an extra play.
I have a 2.7k play.
We have one thing.
Alright, Cody, I have a very serious question for you.
Alright, forget passing.
I have a very serious question.
I noticed in your top games of 2023 and 2024 there was no mention of Resident Evil 4 Remake.
Have you never played that game?
That bothers me to this day.
No, it was good.
It was pretty good.
Okay, I just needed clarification.
Because I was like, there's no way you've never played Resident Evil 4.
No, you don't play games?
Yes, okay.
Cody doesn't play games.
He only reacts to TikToks.
Nice.
And videos.
It's crazy.
She is 19 years old.
That is unbelievable.
Are we good?
That is amazing.
That's crazy.
We all just casually walked away from the extraction point.
Why did nobody hit the extraction point?
I will do it.
She's doing it.
Wait.
Oh.
We're good.
Now we gotta get back, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know.
But it's a scary boy.
It's the boy.
It's the Marshmallow Man.
It's the Ghostbusters.
Oh my god, I see it.
I see the scary boy.
You see what, Cody?
The scary boy.
Oh, I thought there wasn't a scary boy.
No, there really is.
He's pretty scary.
Why is it like right here?
Like it actually knows we're here.
Because the monsters attract sound.
Oh, we're moving right now.
It's good to go.
Leave right now.
Yeah.
It's good to go.
It's good?
Keep going?
Yeah, you guys got it.
No, no, no.
I promise it's safe.
What is that?
Oh, he said...
He's gone.
Why are you staring at it?
He's right there!
Okay, he's not even chasing us.
Do I have to go up?
I didn't know that.
Ew.
He's right there.
We're safe though.
He doesn't see me.
Hello?
Oh, monsters in there.
Okay.
You know the monsters are attracted by sound, right?
Hello?
This way they get away from you guys, you know?
Who else is alive in this hallway?
Oh, everyone.
Cool.
We made it.
We did it.
We all made it.
Let's go.
Gaming.
For some reason, we can still work together.
For some reason.
More upgrades, please.
Yes, feed.
Feed Coney.
Our strat is to feed Coney.
Veggie time.
More strength, please.
Got you, strength.
There's a giant baseball bat here if you want this.
Oh, what?
Wait, that's pretty good.
We gotta give him stamina upgrade.
I would like speed.
I want speed, dude.
Speed is... I'm very fast.
Aren't you already really fast?
Oh my god.
Don't step on that, Coney.
He's becoming self-aware.
He knows what he wants now.
Oh, shit.
That's what he wants.
Wait, should we get health?
Actually, wait a minute.
I just realized we might need HP.
I'll get rid of...
We all lived, right?
I have 33 HP.
What are you doing?
I think that's good.
Alright, gotta get those electrolytes in our system.
Welcome back.
Alright, let's go!
Level 5!
Does your kid watch TikToks?
No!
I love my kid.
I'm not letting her do that.
Can I have the health?
I need health.
Shall we?
Just take everything.
Eat up, Coney.
Become big and strong.
I have 3 strength.
Oh my god, he's so fast.
I got the zoobies!
Alright, headman Manny.
Wait, this is the shotgun map, right?
Shotgun map?
You said that last time.
No, this one, for real, is the guy with the shotgun.
He reacts to sound.
Oh, the enemy has a shotgun?
Yeah, so enemy one-shots you.
Like, pause in my mic?
Yeah.
Anything up here?
There's like, several floors now.
Guys, I have...
There's several stuff upstairs.
Okay.
Woah!
It's bouncing around!
I hope, like, the strat of giving...
pumping Coney with as many...
with as many steroids as possible works out for us.
Put him in the cart.
I hope.
I hope the strat would work out.
There's one here.
Alright, I got the compass.
Coney is the ADC.
Is it actually working now?
I can't tell.
Wait, what's inside there?
You dropped something.
Well, I got it.
Ooh, I'm risking it all.
For a shortcut.
It's 8k.
Wait, we have enough.
No, wait, I can't math.
We need, like, one more item.
Somebody's dead.
What?
Already?
How do you know?
Is that their head?
You can see the red dot, yeah.
Oh!
I think they fell into the hole.
Did you guys kill them?
Did you throw his head in there?
He threw his head in there!
He said Coney wasn't strongest of all.
I had to correct him.
Alright, I got him.
Put him in the cart.
What do you mean you had to correct him?
What did you do?
He said I wasn't the strongest.
What does that mean?
Oh, we need 200.
Oh, that should be enough.
It wasn't.
He needs correction.
Alright, you can handle the cart.
Or do something super risky.
What
are you doing?
What are you doing?
We're in this together, what are you doing?
No, he tried to kill me.
So now I'm doing this.
We violated the social contract.
There it goes.
I picked it up.
Just get the doll to make up for it.
It's right there.
Get the doll.
Minus $7,000.
Because...
Oh, not the clock.
Where are you even taking it?
We're done with it.
Don't drop it.
I'm holding on.
Kony, are you actually the strongest of them all?
I'm the strongest of all.
You're really the strongest.
Drive me a little cart.
Long live the king.
You truly was the strongest of them all.
I like how the skin's spinning out of his head.
When will we get the head back?
Alright, so...
Oh, there we go.
There's the head.
I see the head.
Where did it go?
It flew so far, I don't even know where it flew to.
It's over here.
He said he was the strongest of them all.
Clearly, he was wrong.
I got the extraction.
Go ahead.
Yeah, there's one down there.
Do you have the doll up there?
Yeah, but the doll's almost dead.
Guys, we don't have our Bidoof anymore, by the way.
I threw him out into the pasture.
We need the cart for the doll, doke.
Our Bidoof is gone.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know what happened to him.
If he was so strong, why is he dead?
Exactly.
I think someone that strong would never die.
The doll...
What is that noise and why?
Bye-bye.
What is that noise?
I don't know.
I was like, tell me you didn't die to that.
I was just praying.
If strong, why dead?
Exactly.
That's my philosophy.
Can't be the strongest if he's dead.
Oh my god, sorry.
Where's the cart?
Right here, right here, right here.
Oh, there it is.
We got some stuff to explore.
Hold on.
There's hope.
We're close.
There's a diamond?
Oh, it's not worth that much.
Oh, there's the big boy.
Are you strong enough solo?
No.
There you are.
You can do it.
Oh my god.
Long live the king.
Oops.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Don't use the tree alive, I'm not even kidding.
I think it's a sandbar.
Have you played Monster Hunter?
He's like the conga lala.
He is actually the conga lala.
Okay, move it, move it.
Move the cart to the first extraction.
The second one, to the second extraction.
Can we close the door?
He's gonna open it.
I'll keep looking for more stuff.
Wait, is it 15k?
How much do we have?
Oh, we got enough.
We literally just got enough.
I hope I don't drop it.
Yeah, I'm watching you right now, Void.
I'm watching you.
We have only...
If you drop it, it's you.
You fucked us over.
It's true.
You were the one that fucked us over.
You drop it right now.
And Kony would have to wait just a little longer.
Oh, really?
I think Matt caught COVID or something up there.
Kony's gonna remember that he's spectating us right now.
What are we laughing about?
What happened?
Our $1.
It's okay, Kony.
Welcome back.
I thought we were over by $1.
Is this all $1?
Kony, do you think you're still the strongest of them all?
Nobody is strong without friends.
That's what I've come to learn.
Over the course of my...
Friendship is the strongest thing.
How much HP do you have, Kony?
The power of friendship, everybody.
I have 1 HP.
I can give you some.
Yeah, do that.
With the power of friendship, we prevail.
Bro said some and gave me 10.
Thank you.
Thank you, man.
What do I look like with 10?
Ah, what is that?
What is that?
You wanna find out?
I think he's trying to...
I think he wants the dollar, guys.
That $1?
Our $1.
I think he wants the dollar.
Give him a dollar!
That's a Soul Calibur character.
Who is that?
The survivor.
She's like blocking us.
The extraction is literally right there.
Oh, it's a girl?
I don't know.
She's thick as hell.
She heard you.
That's a compliment!
Ladies night!
Oh, bangers, bangers, bangers.
What?
What are those?
I went the wrong way.
Why did we leave the cart in front?
Oh, what happened?
Who exploded?
Oh, we're about to lose our $1.
We had nothing in there.
We had one full dollar.
Why did I just take damage?
What are you doing?
Don't throw me out there.
I didn't do anything.
I don't trust Doki.
Oh my god!
It sucked me up!
What?
It pulls me closer!
I didn't think he'd pull me closer!
What?
How did it hit me and not him?
That's not fair!
I didn't deserve that.
I did so much for this team.
You even complimented her and everything.
I called her thick as hell.
It was a compliment.
I can't believe it.
She doesn't appreciate me.
A fellow woman.
Maybe she didn't like that.
It's a compliment!
Come here, boy!
Come here,
boy!
Women against women.
We need to stick together!
As fellow women!
We gotta work together!
A women month!
Let's watch Kony.
Our fellow Bidoof.
Is our Bidoof doing okay?
I can't believe it.
I worked so hard.
Oh my god, he's so strong.
He just lifts it like that.
What's our Bidoof doing?
What's our Bidoof doing right now?
I can't believe it.
I bet she was a pick me woman too.
She was a pick me girl.
She didn't like that I was also hanging out with the bros.
She was like, only me.
Can't believe it.
We were supposed to be working together.
A group can have two women!
A group doesn't need one woman!
It can have two!
Maybe three women!
Possibilities are endless!
It does not have to be like the Smurf village!
We can all be Smurfette!
We can all be Amy!
They didn't even grab my head!
Oh no, I'm alive.
Oh my god, okay, I'm alive.
Does anyone have any HP to spare?
I'm like 1 HP.
There's the goose lady.
Put that down!
Goose lady!
Oh shit!
One of us are dead.
Two of us are dead.
Ow!
Sorry.
Oh god.
What are you running from?
What do you think I'm running from?
What do you think?
There's 20 things down there!
You can toss them.
I'm okay.
I'll go forward then.
Oh my god, I got jumpscared by myself.
Get away from me!
You're gonna throw up on me!
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Get away!
Bro, I can't.
I can't.
I don't know.
Bro, what are you talking about?
He's in the way!
The thing is up here blocking the way.
Get away from
me!
It won't fall into the thing, bro.
Move!
Oh!
It might be over!
No!
Get away!
Oh my god!
We're getting blocked by that thing!
We can't go that way.
Get away!
Watch out behind you, doggy.
There's a guy.
Is there another way to get over there?
Are you fucking kidding me?
No!
Get away from me!
Get away!
Oh my god!
I'm sorry, bro.
I'm sorry.
I can't.
I can't make it.
Oh, you made it!
Oh my god.
You made it!
Oh my god!
What the fuck is wrong with you?
You were holding my head!
Listen.
Why did you not do it?
You dropped the head!
I didn't think...
That was for the clock, Cody.
That was for the clock, man.
You had three seconds!
I want my juicies!
I want juicies.
That'll help me feel better.
I want one apple.
We need a health pack.
We're so fucking low.
Give me my juice.
Yeah, health pack, too.
For me.
And then we can buy another health pack.
We'll buy a mini one.
I can't believe we lived.
I can't believe we lived that.
Alright, that should be enough.
Are you picking the hammer?
We have zero funds.
Let's go!
Okay, I hope that's worth it.
Oh, there he is.
Is Void okay?
Is he traumatized?
Is he okay?
I don't think he's okay.
He's just sitting in the corner.
By himself.
He looks like he's seen things.
Eat up and be a big strong boy.
Look how fast I am.
Give some HP.
That's not even fair.
That's our Bidoof.
I can't even track that.
Give some HP.
Give it to Void and Matt.
I got 29.
You have plenty.
Give some to Matt.
I don't like this.
Now you understand why I was in trouble.
There's nothing explicitly bad, but it's just weird.
Alright, Kony, here's your fucking 12k hammer that you bought.
Yay!
I got my prize!
We could have had a health pack, but you bought a fucking hammer.
I did so good.
I deserve it.
Guys,
what house are you in?
I'm a Gryffindor.
Yeah, I'm a Gryffindor too.
You would be a Hufflepuff, so true.
Oh, this is actually very Harry Potter-like.
Oh wait, there's the potions.
Oh, I can put it in my inventory.
Thank you, chat.
A check!
Wait, does it do damage when you stand in there?
Wait!
Kony!
Kony, get over here!
What is he doing?
I think he's dead.
Get this cube.
We have another mega cube here too.
You guys don't need a third, I just want to do something.
Wait, Kony, we need you to do this too.
Okay, I'll do it too, don't worry.
Wait, where did Void go?
Oh, you can just bring it to the thingy.
Yeah, that's 20k.
Wait, did he actually die?
Yes, he stood in this.
And then he exploded.
There's a clown.
That's just Kony.
Is it Harry Potter?
There's a clown.
Oh, it is a clown!
I don't like that.
Oh god.
Beat his ass, Kony, don't worry.
Wait, he's alive!
He's coming, he's coming.
Let him round this corner.
Wait for him to round this corner.
No, he left.
He left, he left.
He knows.
Just Tom and Jerry shit.
He's coming back, he's coming back!
Why did you hit me?
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Thanks, thanks.
I'll give him one of these.
One of these.
Can I rotate it?
I don't know.
Right click, yeah.
Yeah, we're loony tuning this shit right now.
I got my card right here.
I don't know if that's gonna do any damage, Kony.
It's like...
It costs 12k!
It's more expensive than a fucking health pack!
I'm going this way, guys.
See you later.
Sayonara.
Wait, what the fuck was that?
I had a peepee head.
There's something in front of us.
What the fuck was that?
There was a peepee head in front of us.
How much money do we have in there?
Oh, it's just 9k.
There's a peepee head alien in front of us.
Oh, there's a life potion.
Kony, don't look behind you.
Kony got you, kid.
I was trying to save him.
Did he get you killed?
Oh,
no.
He doesn't know what to do.
Kony, there's two clowns.
Wait, there's two?
There's two.
I think we fucked up by not buying any guns.
I think we fucked up.
It's okay, we have a hammer.
We have a 12k hammer.
Money well spent.
Where are the others?
What kind of fucking adventure are they doing?
They're having a grand old time.
Oh, no.
The two people that are actually doing anything are dead.
I'm saying...
that we have our Bidoof.
It's okay.
We have our Bidoof.
It's a playable hammer.
It's okay.
The perfect weapon for our maxed out, roided Bidoof.
I believe in Kony.
Wait, he didn't pick up my head.
Oh my god.
I think Brawpro doesn't know how to res you.
He put you in the recharge station.
Why did he put me in the recharge station?
Somebody go to Brawpro chat right now and tell them to put me in the other extraction.
Someone tell him.
Someone tell him to put me in.
Don't let him do this to me.
Okay, okay.
He figured it out.
Big fucking guy.
He fucking figured it out.
Don't worry.
He's not that clumsy.
He literally just need $200.
We got it.
I believe.
Why did he get us?
You're racist.
I blame Kony.
I blame Kony too.
100%.
It wasn't our fault.
Yeah, we were there to protect him.
He was literally right in front of them and yet it kills you and me?
I blame my Bidoof.
Yeah, we should've got Zigzagoon.
Oh true.
We got a fucking Bidoof.
It's gonna evolve into something ugly like Bibera.
Yeah.
At least he's eradicated.
And what's the other one?
Limune?
You guys only like Bidoof ironically.
You guys don't actually like Bidoof.
Look at what Bidoof just did.
Look at what he did.
Are you still gonna defend our Bidoof?
Look at this guy.
Oh my god, dude.
That just broke the vase.
It was like $6,000.
He dropped it.
Oh, a gnome!
Is that a duck?
That's a bad guy!
No way!
He has an inflatable hammer.
He's gonna get the gnome.
Liz, you just need $200!
How hard is it to find $200?
The economy right now is kinda grim.
I believe in him.
He has
a party.
He has a party of gnomes.
Look at him.
I'm gonna release this Bidoof into the wilds.
Oh, nice.
They're actually just climbing.
Wait, did they take my hammer?
My hammer's gone!
Coney.
Coney!
Dude,
he took my stuff!
Oh my god!
Are you serious?
Oh, there's my hammer.
Coney, stop focusing on the hammer!
I killed the duck, or would the duck kill me if I hammered him?
Bidoof!
That's so funny.
I didn't think there was a way Coney could ruin it.
Oh no, and then Matt...
Matt probably will have to clown on them.
You totally didn't fuck up, did you?
The gnome did.
We were talking about Tekken and everything.
He led the gnomes to the treasure.
He did!
He led them to everything!
No, I need more.
Get another thing.
It's okay, we got this.
There's still three of us alive.
I'm spectating you, Matt, and I saw it.
I saw it all, Matt.
I saw it all.
Matt, if he fucking fell into the pit with that...
He's playing with fire.
Minus 2,900.
If I die, my blood is on your hand!
What?
Brawl Pro, no!
There's a frogman over there, too.
Minus 3,600.
Goodbye.
Hello, Brawl Pro.
Hey, how's it going?
Those guys are boring anyways.
I'm glad to be here.
Okay, so what Coney did...
He led the gnomes to all the treasure.
And then the gnomes started hitting the treasure.
Oh my god.
And then Coney was like, What happened?
Coney didn't know where his hammer was.
The hammer was on the ground.
And the hammer exploded.
Push the cart forward!
Push the cart forward, Matt!
Bye-bye, cart.
Oh my god.
All right, Brawl Pro, I'll find your body.
Matt!
You told me for it!
Oh my god!
What happened?
Your cart was not fully armed!
Oh.
Oh no.
Wait, what happened?
Oh my god!
I got it, I got it.
Also, Matt, I did see you.
I did see you smash your object.
No, you did not.
You don't need to see that at all.
Here, Coney, look, watch this.
You can do this.
I'll do it.
You can do that, Coney.
If you lead the gnomes...
Please!
Oh my god, nice bonk.
Got him!
Holy fuck!
Do it.
Goodbye.
This is not good.
Where's the other extraction, though?
It's just the two of us.
Just the two of us.
Where the fuck is the third extraction?
I thought that was a money bag.
It's a frog.
It's the alien and the frog.
Where the fuck is the next extraction?
I'm running.
There?
Yippee!
Let's get 14k by ourselves!
Wait, we're missing one person.
Oh yeah, RawPro.
I don't remember where he died.
Wait, all of this is almost explored.
I'm a little worried here.
This might be where we caught GaloGG's, guys.
It was a good run.
It was a really good run, guys.
Just the two of us.
Okay, we gotta stick together.
We're both 1 HP.
We have to stick together.
Wait, where are you?
I'm upstairs.
Wait, there's an upstairs?
Yeah.
How did you get upstairs?
Guess we're not sticking together.
There's a stairway over here.
I have to push this cube off.
I'm not strong enough.
Wait, how do I go upstairs?
Oh, it's here.
There's another head.
That's RawPro.
I'll grab it later.
Yeah, I'm upstairs.
Wait, I'm at the wrong upstairs.
Wait, I'm at a different upstairs.
Where's the upstairs to that upstairs?
Okay, we gotta stick together.
I found RawPro's head.
Okay, I found a cube.
I'm trying to do what I can with my limited strength.
I can't believe our Bidoof died.
I know, right?
What's the point?
After all the veggies and roids we gave him.
Wait, how do we do this?
This is gonna be hard.
How do we...
Why is it so high up?
Come on.
We got this.
Oh god.
We're not strong enough.
Where is our Bidoof when we need him?
Put it on the right side of the stairs.
I'm gonna let go.
Okay.
No, I'm gonna push.
I push, you pull.
There we go.
It's right there.
Oh, I have an idea.
We did it.
Nice.
Oh, that's a little awkward.
We can just push it.
Okay.
Nice.
We're almost there.
How did you get upstairs last time?
Over here.
Okay, okay.
Is there more stuff?
I'm gonna check this little balcony area.
Yeah, there typically is.
Alright.
Now there's nothing left.
Oh no, it's empty.
Oh wait, no, there's one thing.
There's a froggy.
Oh, there's an expensive thing over here.
Yeah.
It's just $50, guys.
I only lost $50, it's fine.
1 HP and a dream.
Oh!
5k more.
Do you need help with the last thing?
Uh, there's two more things.
One is like 20k.
Oh god.
Okay, one is 20k.
Okay.
I'm heading up.
Let me try and grab it.
Where is it?
What's 20k?
Is it the broom?
Uh, there's a...
A wizard frog staff.
What is the broom?
There's a secret room over here.
Wait, there's a secret?
Oh my god.
Oh fuck.
Oh my god, a secret.
Oh my god.
Can't do it.
Wait, I got this.
Wait, I can help.
Oh!
I see.
There's a frog.
Okay, you got it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If that hits a wall, it might shoot a laser beam.
Okay, you jumped down.
Okay, and then you hold it.
Okay.
I don't trust myself.
Okay, if you hit that, that's gonna shoot yourself.
You're gonna shoot yourself.
Yeah.
I'm gonna let go.
Okay, cool.
I'll grab the other head.
Okay, I'm grabbing the other head.
Wait, that's not where he died.
Oh, he died all the way there?
Okay.
You got it.
No!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, okay.
Wait, did he die?
Did he die?
No, there's two.
No, no, no, no, it's fine.
I see three.
It's fine.
Are you serious?
Are
you fucking serious?
Are you serious?
Oh,
god!
Oh, jesus.
Oh, jesus, Rick.
Please, please, please.
Oh, my god, please come back!
I can't do this alone!
Oh!
We're alive!
Holy moly.
I have one HP!
One whole HP!
There are two clowns.
Okay, when you see a clown and he lasers, just duck.
Duck the lasers.
Okay, got it.
Got it, coach.
Don't mind if I do.
Man, I wish we had a cart.
I wonder what happened to that cart.
Oh, there's a giant thing here.
Yeah.
Ironically, literally every doll... be careful.
Oh, my god.
Yeah, we actually can't...
Man, I wish we still had that staff.
Yeah.
Oh!
What?
No.
I can help you.
I'm helping you right now.
Are we going any faster right now?
Are we going any faster?
Whoa, we're going so fast!
Why is my whole team is chopped and screwed?
Okay, put it down carefully.
Put it down carefully.
Guys, we actually did it.
Oh, my god, we did.
Okay, one HP.
We gotta get back home.
I'm leaving now.
Bye-bye.
Goodbye.
Every man for himself.
Only one person has to make it back.
Scatter!
I said scatter.
Oh, my god.
I didn't know who it was.
Shh!
Some of them are triggered by something.
Don't be so scared!
We made it.
Woo!
Oh, thank you.
Go team!
We did it!
Oh, nice.
Oh, my god, we all made it.
Everybody made it!
We all made it.
Oh, my god.
We have a run, guys.
This is a big run.
Oh, my god, dude.
Dude, put a bunch of gamers in a single repo lobby.
See what happens.
Holy shit.
Okay, guys.
We are not buying any hammers.
We're buying HP, guys.
It's fine.
We need help.
Fine.
A sword!
Let's just drink.
We might have to kill them.
I was gonna say, what if we had to kill the bad guys?
There were two clowns last time.
There's a health upgrade here.
Technically, we should be like...
Do we have enough for like any upgrades?
Range, stamina...
I gotta go potty.
Okay, I can get stamina.
Okay.
Flush him.
I got a hat.
I better not get flushed.
You're getting washed.
Oh, thank you.
This is great.
I'm like an infant.
Holy shit.
I'm an infant.
I guess she saw the last Street Fighter Slim.
Oh, god.
Don't bring that up.
I went like 210.
Don't bring it up, Kody.
Okay, Kody, Kody, but you won Twitch Rivals, so that's all you want Twitch Rivals.
Kody, remember that.
I know.
I was talking about we would 0-7.
Dude.
It's okay.
It's a creed.
I'm not Twitch Rivals.
Press Q.
Oh, never mind.
I'm okay.
I'll go in the car.
I want to go in the car, too.
Me, too.
Let's go.
Free samples.
I want a snack.
I want free samples.
I want Lucky Charms.
They don't have Lucky Charms here.
Ehhh Oh
I think I deserve HP after the fucking clutch I did.
Wait, what happened to it?
You know what happened to it.
My hammer's back.
I don't think you should be allowed to use the hammer, Kody.
Oh, he's covetous of my hammer.
Okay.
That's not what I'm saying.
No, I think my chat's right.
We definitely start buying weapons now.
We gotta kill things.
Level 7 is pretty far in, right?
Level 7 is the best I've ever done.
Which is like right now.
This is the best you've ever done, Matt.
Holy shit.
You're right.
There's nothing like...
up top.
Where's our cart?
Oh, a clown!
Already?
Oh, no.
A good clown.
Oh, I thought you meant...
There's something here.
The map says there's...
Oh, wait.
No.
It was on the other side.
It's moving.
That's just what Kody, I think, picked up.
Oh, there's...
Oh, you can go up here?
What's this level design?
There's nothing here, though.
Oh, God.
There's an outside.
There's a bomb.
There's nothing here.
Oh, there is.
There's a face.
Tiny little face.
How much is that worth?
$2,000.
$2,000?
That's a lot for what that is.
Wait, check the locker.
Check the locker.
I got something.
I got $1,000.
Did we ever get our cart back?
I'm not sure.
Hey, guys.
Did we ever get our cart back or no?
We should have it back.
Yeah, yeah.
We got it back.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Alright, we got one here.
How much do we have right now?
Okay, nine.
Oh, this is where we start.
Head, head, head, head, head through that door.
Head through that door on the right.
Dude, I hate that thing.
Someone has to lead him.
We have to lead him somewhere else because if he goes to our items, we're fucked.
A chalice.
The holy grail.
Wait, how do they go to that side?
Oh, is it this way?
Where?
Parkour.
What do I do with parkour?
You crouch, you crouch.
When you crouch, your flat plate turns off.
Is there anything up here?
Oh, shit.
No, no, no.
Just keep pressing it.
I'm not.
I'm losing HP.
I can't tell.
I don't even remember how much HP I lost.
How much HP I had.
Yeah, he doesn't like that.
Oh!
Is there anything downstairs?
Oh, I want the guitar.
I thought there was no fog that much.
I think I lied to you.
I can't believe people just lie on the internet like that.
I am a strong...
I'm a big boy.
I'm a... Mommy says I'm a big boy.
Look at that.
Big boy.
Look at that big boy doing big boy things.
No!
Please!
Sounds like a void problem.
What the fuck is that?
What happened?
What the fuck?
There's an eyeball on the ceiling.
Oh yeah, I just break L.O.S.
But it's hard to do.
Eyeball?
Where?
The guitar fucking blocked me from the beginning.
The guitar was so big.
I couldn't...
I didn't see him.
There's nothing here.
Are you okay?
Where did it go?
I'm so sad.
Are you okay?
The guitar blocked me from playing in real life.
What the fuck was that?
Somebody has to believe me.
Guys!
I believe you, Cody.
I believe you.
I believe you, dude.
Wait, who broke this door?
I believe you, Cody.
I believe you.
Is there anything up there?
No.
I saw the guitar.
I saw something fall down the stairs on the map.
It was like...
It was me.
I'm something.
I can't believe it.
I was showing everyone how much of a big boy I was.
And then the guitar blocked my field of vision so I didn't see the giant head until it started screaming at me.
The guitar was the big boy all along.
The guitar was the big boy.
Sad.
I'm gonna grab water.
I'll be right back, guys.
He was trying to scare me, but I was like...
Dude, I was like, wait, is that a monster?
The thing looked like a red tentacle.
The flashlight, so I thought there really was something.
Wait, this thing is worth 21k.
Money here, too.
Hello?
Money?
I'll just put it in the cart.
Everybody left.
Everybody left me.
Yet again.
If you get a certain amount, does it roll over or no?
No, right?
It does?
Is that Doki's head?
Doki, what happened to you?
Alright, let me get this big ass server.
I think I'm too strong.
Where's the cart?
Oh, I see it.
Hold on, I'm taking this.
A guitar?
Oh my god, what's ahead?
What's happening?
Oh my god.
I'm still the only one dead!
It's not fair!
Cody was the right POV to watch.
Oh my god!
Cody, you stupid fucking abber!
Motherfucker!
There's a baby that chucked some money at me.
Wait, how is that a bad thing?
I mean, streamers...
Oh, Cody...
What's the point of giving him so much strength if he can't even carry it?
What the fuck was the point?
I got like double...
I had a guitar on me and I didn't realize there was a head in front of me because the guitar was bigger than my field of vision.
Yeah, I was struggling with that too.
Yeah, and then I was like, yippee!
The head guy screamed at me and then I saw him when he was this close to my face.
And then I ran downstairs and then I got eyed.
The Soran Eye got me.
And then they just...
literally comboed.
I just got comboed.
There was no hope.
I can't believe Cody is the one that survives out of all of this.
Yeah, we literally BDoofed him.
We literally...
Did he just die?
I'm done, brother.
I am done.
Is that not water?
What is that?
What is my team doing?
No way.
The pool killed everyone.
We all died to the pool.
Why did nobody tell me there was water behind me?
Oh, I'm sorry!
I died!
I...
Cody, by the way, I saw the eye, Cody.
I saw it.
I'm outvalidated.
I was the only one that saw it, because I was dead.
Because that's what killed me, too.
My diamond also lost value.
Where's my head?
Because I had 4k on that server.
There's no way he can get the server.
Hold on.
Wait, can he not move the cart?
No, he can, but he's trying to Tetris this.
He's trying to Tetris it.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, he's trying to Tetris everything.
He takes something out of the cart, hoping it's a treasure, and it's just dead heads every time.
I mean, we have a good amount.
He just needs to make a couple trips.
Why is he taking it one by one?
I think that's enough Tetris.
Now he's like...
Yeah, now he's Tetris-ing a little.
They're all so small, too.
Maybe he's trying to take cart with him, you know?
Or maybe he's just AFK.
How much HP does he have?
A lot.
He has 100.
If he leaves the cart behind, I have no justification for what he just did.
Why did he do that?
Oh, I think the server blew up.
That's what it was.
Wait, why did he not even take...
Why did he do all that?
I don't understand.
Why is he not bringing the cart with him?
Oh, and he breaks the doors.
Knocked out the gamer.
Oh, what's that?
Something?
That's a chainsaw.
What, she missed?
Oh my god, that's actually a thing.
There's no way.
You see the yellow dot.
There it is!
Oh, he has enough strength.
Wait, can you kill Can you kill enemies with that?
I think you can, yeah.
But he can't touch anything or the blades get dulled.
If something hears me because of this, you got it.
What did he say?
Oh yeah, they can hear him, probably.
It's fine, he'll chop the head.
Yeah, yeah.
Surely this is worth 5k.
Oh, but then it can also hit the items.
It can also hit the items, too.
Oh, he needs one...
Oh, he needs to move it a little closer because it can get destroyed.
It's like literally against the wall.
He can make it.
That thing up top, that's a laptop.
That's possible when he sees it.
I believe in him.
PogChamp.
Oh my god!
How did that even happen?
Oh, it's over.
He's trying to fight it, he should just leave.
No, he only lost 10 HP.
Oh, he's full HP, I thought he was one.
No, no, no.
He lost nothing.
He got the 100 HP thingy and he didn't share.
How much does a laptop cost?
It said he lost a thousand there, so...
I mean, I don't know about you guys, but...
We're back, we're back!
Void's gonna share his HP with all of us, right?
Surely, surely, surely.
Right?
I certainly won't be one HP the entire game.
Everybody say heal me when we come back.
Okay, okay, here we go, here we go.
Heal me, heal me, heal me!
Heal me, heal me, heal me, heal me!
What are you doing?
You would rather die?
He's like...
He doesn't wanna work anymore, that was nuts.
I've never had more than one HP.
That was his final retirement.
He could've gave you some and then died.
He could have given us...
He could have healed us and then he's dead.
He could have healed us first.
He just went in.
Why are we putting his head in the cart?
That's true, you're right, you're so right.
He threw that shit.
He threw that shit at us, bro.
He threw that for us.
That's crazy.
Alright, I found a clown.
Hong Kong.
Here we go.
Wait, Kony.
What?
Yeah?
I need your strength up here.
Say no more.
Oh shit, wait.
Hey, that's it.
What is it?
Yeah.
It's Bill's PC.
Wait, who broke this fucking door?
Okay.
Okay, we might need him actually.
Yeah, bring his head.
Oh, minus 2k.
Okay,
you guys just slowly bring it over.
Okay, I'll help you.
I don't want to fall in the water again.
There's no water.
We looked.
You're good, keep going.
Right side, right, right, right.
Oh, I see it.
Make a right turn.
Okay, we gotta make sure we place it in a way where it doesn't get crushed.
Okay?
There.
Guys, guys, guys.
Guys, guys.
That is not clean.
Okay, we need 1k.
Just grab 1k.
Yeah, no, I grabbed his head.
Grab 2 items.
Don't put the cart in.
We don't have room for the cart.
Oh, really?
Yeah, we don't.
Just grab items from it.
This clown will be enough.
Yeah.
He's gonna be part of this.
There you go.
Clown goes on.
And then we get it.
We have enough.
Just bring the cart back up.
I wanna do it.
We have enough.
It's in.
I got it.
Alright, Void's back.
Void is coming back.
He has to be part of this game.
Heal me.
It's okay, guys.
The health was a crutch.
Right, right, right.
Yeah, you're so right.
We might as well not buy health packs after this.
Right, guys?
Yeah, we don't need health packs.
Oh, head.
Head.
He went left to right.
He's on the right.
He's still right.
He's still there.
He's in this room.
Yeah, he's big chillin'.
We gotta watch out for the thing on the ground.
I'm gonna go in this room and see if it's extraction.
Hold on.
Okay, it should be at the end.
It's so wittable.
Oh my god, we're doing it.
We're so...
Look, this ice cube is worth literally all we need.
We need coding.
We actually...
Is two people enough?
Okay, but like...
You gotta make sure I don't fucking fall.
Just look down and look at the wood.
You want me to...
Okay, okay.
You go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I believe.
Okay.
Yeah, I can do it.
Here we go.
Are you doing it?
Yeah, I'm good.
I swear I'm good.
Wait, I'm not doing it either, though.
I'm not looking down, guys.
Just hold straight.
I gotta lift it a little bit.
It was the thing that was looping me.
I need like a third person in the lockers.
It's like stuck on the wood.
There's never anything in the lockers.
Yeah.
Usually when there is, like...
Can I get a third person?
We need a third person here.
I need help lifting this, but it's gonna be kinda...
Okay.
No, he's alive somewhere.
Then we don't have a strength meister.
Wait, did he actually die?
Yeah, I saw him.
What killed him?
How many do you have on this side?
That's the problem.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I don't trust myself.
Someone else do it.
Okay.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
That's all.
I'm good.
Okay.
There you go.
Should I take this cart down there?
Once they're done.
If you accidentally ram somebody, you might...
You might die.
Okay.
That's Kony, right?
Inside the ice cube, right?
Yeah, he's stuck in here.
That's Kony right there.
I thought he was gonna get squished.
What the heck?
I don't know, hold on.
Diagonal mode is probably better.
Oh, we need to fit the cart.
We still need to fit the cart.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, if we push it like this then, no?
What about make it vertical?
There you go, like this.
This is good, this is good.
Wait, do you have Kony's head?
Wait, we don't have Kony's head, guys!
Wait, wait, wait, we don't have Kony yet.
Yeah, yeah, put it back.
Take it out, take it out.
We don't have Kony's head.
Where is his head?
I don't know, I'll go on a journey, bye.
Yeah, we'll just wait.
It's red on the map, no?
Somebody's seen it, it's red.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that means none of us have seen his head.
Kony!
Are they dead?
Are you guys alive?
Yes, they are, they are, they are.
What's over there?
Yeah, just try to find height.
Oh, we didn't find Kony.
Okay, well, I guess we're just going to deal with...
I guess Kony's not coming back, then.
Yeah.
He's somewhere, I could try.
No, let's just...
No, it's every man for themselves again.
It's not.
We could use our 8 gems, please.
There's a baby.
Is he worth anything?
Well, I actually think that's Kony reincarnated.
No?
Wait, really?
I don't think that's possible.
He's trying to show us the way, look at him.
Look at Kony.
Come back, Kony.
Kony said that definitely don't look for his head.
We should just go.
Okay, okay, okay.
That means he ran somewhere.
He definitely got, like, crumpled somewhere.
I do not want to get you to the end!
Oh, look at that!
I found Kony.
I found him.
What?
What just happened to me?
I don't know.
What happened to voice?
What just happened to me?
I teleported.
How did you do it?
Are you cheating?
Why are you alive?
You fell off the edge.
Doki, I cannot believe you found me.
That is insane.
Where were you?
You were in the same closet I was in.
He was in the closet.
Because I was hiding.
I was like, I found him.
I found him.
Holy shit.
A gun!
Can I buy it?
Buy a gun.
I want the gun.
It's my gun.
Let's get ready.
We have to share 100 HP.
Put me down.
We have a gun.
Let me run to the bathroom real quick.
It would be nice to be at that sledgehammer.
Guys, guys, guys.
While he's in the bathroom, quick.
I'm still fucking here, dude.
Okay, okay, quick, quick, quick.
Go, go, go, go, go.
He's in the bathroom.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
I got him in, I got him in.
Let me out, let me down.
No.
He's gotta go potty.
Time to go potty, little man.
Don't kiss head.
Give him a swirly.
Yeah, dude.
That's right.
That's right, dude.
Let's give him that swirly.
Get in there, get in there, get in there.
Time for a swirly, dude.
It's so gross.
Ow.
All right.
Put Cody in the toilet.
Put Cody in, put Cody in.
You're right, you're right.
Cody's next.
Put Cody in this one, put Cody in this one.
That's right.
Get swirly, dude.
Get swirly.
Yeah.
Gonna pull the handle.
I tried to save you.
It's a fucking lie, you know it.
You laughed.
You laughed with us.
What was going on?
Nothing much, nothing much.
Team bonding, you know.
Just gave Cody a swirly, felt amazing.
Is that a high school right there?
Press Q real quick.
My head stinks now.
No, I'm not gonna hit Q.
He actually hit Q.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I think there's a secret thing up here.
Five, four, three, two, one.
I won't forget you, buddy.
Where's my gun?
Where's my firearm?
Don't worry, chat.
I'm curious, can you shoot me?
What?
We have limited ammo.
Do not shoot the gun.
Oh, I'm fine.
I think you missed, Cody.
Try it again.
Low HP, there's 50 here.
Be please.
Shall we?
Cheers, my friends.
Does that actually consume my bullet?
Yes, it does.
I think it comes back.
I'm not sure.
You can refresh it with this machine.
The yellow machine.
Yeah, but we need to buy the crystals to refresh it.
Back at Hogwarts.
Do we have enough crystals for it?
This place was pretty fucked up.
I'm gonna shoot the shit out of the guy I see.
We haven't seen the shotgun guy yet, by the way.
Yeah, we haven't.
It's only in the manor.
It's only in the manor where he appears.
Oh, I hear a baby left.
Already?
Oh, what was that baby?
Is he...
Don't go in here, you die.
There's an extraction here, guys.
Oh, there is.
Right away?
That's a fast extraction.
Oh, I saw someone drop something.
I saw someone drop something.
Oh, it's the screamer, it's the screamer.
Wait, the screamer's already here?
Yeah, I think something happened.
I don't know.
Anything else here?
Oh, nice.
Oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh!
Check this!
Oh, no, I threw the gun!
I threw the gun!
That's the one thing we have!
Hold on, worry not.
I'll blast her.
You missed three times in a row.
And then he died.
Is he coming here?
He's coming, he's coming, he's coming!
He's coming!
Where is he?
Does anybody know?
Hey, Kony's dead.
Don't worry.
I'll shoot her.
Yeah, he...
He missed a couple of shots on her.
Uh, there's a sword.
I put the sword back, I put the sword in.
Um,
so...
Um, a monster came in and destroyed all our loot.
Yeah, that happens.
Is that the sword?
Yeah,
I think I need a little help.
We got no vitamins, no veggies.
Yeah, we gave it to the one guy that died.
We gave it to the guy that also had a gun.
We also gave him a gun and he still died.
Hey, so this is $16,000.
Right here.
Do we have enough?
Can we pick this up or no?
I got the head, I got the head.
Wait, guys, this is $16,000.
Can we...
Oh, it looks like we can move it?
Together?
Oh, no, it's on budgeting.
Yeah, it is.
I can't move it, I'm trying to.
I'm moving it.
Yeah, see, we got it.
Hey, I didn't see the hole.
Oops.
I don't even think BroPro noticed.
He's gonna be like, wait, where's...
He has no idea what just happened.
He didn't even see the hole.
He didn't even see me.
I'm in bed.
I'm actually clueless of your presence.
He doesn't know you're dead.
Hold on, I'm not gonna tell him.
We're gonna come back, I'm not gonna tell him.
I'm gonna be like, oh, shit.
I'm gonna ask him where you are.
Okay, let's go.
Alright, let's go.
Here we go.
Everybody okay?
Are you okay?
Yeah, where's Doki?
Uh, she went this way, I think.
She...
went...
this way.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so...
BroPro?
What happened?
Me?
What do you mean?
You killed her, man.
How?
Was it you, Kony?
Did you shoot her?
This is like an Among Us moment.
Okay.
I'll show you a clip, please.
Alright, I found a... what is this?
A sword!
What happened?
She went this way.
I did so bad.
Guys.
Oh, no.
I was actually fucked up.
I got it.
No, I'm very strong.
Kony is strongest of all.
I got it.
Who wants to play Quidditch?
I can't believe it.
I can't believe they did this to me.
Also, I hope the volume has been okay throughout the stream.
Because that would be awkward if I looked back the stream and you guys couldn't even hear them.
I mean...
Only instructions.
Gather it back.
I'm gonna get one.
Oh, no.
I was making tea.
I think my water has finished boiling.
Let's go find a couple more trinkets.
Nothing down that hallway.
Wait, what was that?
Oh, you healed me.
Thank you.
You, like, jump scared me.
I was like, ah!
Oh, hold on.
Oh, man.
Oh, shit!
How the fuck did you die?
Deserved, honestly.
Fucking deserved.
How did you die?
I got shot!
Wait, the shotgun guy?
Yes!
Oh, fucking funny!
I can't believe...
I was trolling and then I turned around.
That's karma.
That's actual karma.
You could have told me about the fucking pit!
Motherfucker that scared the fuck out of me!
Holy fucking shit!
What was that?
Wait, how did you all die?
Was it shotgun guy?
There's shotgun guy.
It's fucking over.
Look at this.
He's gonna try to kill shotgun guy.
Wait, if you kill shotgun guy, shotgun guy no clipped.
Wait, actually.
He's like under the map.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
I told you he was strong.
I got baby jump scared.
You like disappeared so fast.
Gordon has 1 HP, by the way.
Oh my god.
He's blind.
Yeah, yeah, that's why you don't talk.
Or I guess you could do that.
He's trying to kill him?
No, he's trying to bait him.
He's been playing too much repo.
You know it.
Welcome back to the watch replay repo stream.
He's the hunter.
He's the predator.
This predator versus humans right now.
Yeah, he's like a tiger and flying right now.
Oh my god.
Bro, what the fuck is he doing?
There's the other way.
This and the taking the item.
I don't understand the game.
But maybe he's just better than me.
What is he doing?
He's trying to bait the shot.
Why?
He could go the other way.
No, he has unlimited bullets.
There's another way to go up.
I need 7k.
That went pretty well.
What did he say?
The hard spawn.
Something about a hard spawn.
He said something about a bow tie.
I don't know what that means.
I was like, why is he talking about the bow tie?
What the fuck is a bow tie?
I don't know.
Is he talking repo right now to us?
I don't know the meta.
I don't know that term.
Why did he just bring the cart over just for one day?
I don't understand.
Before he kills himself when we respawn.
Did he gain like 2% extra speed by doing that?
I don't understand.
I don't understand either.
I'm so confused.
You know, I'm surprised how far we made it.
Not gonna lie.
I thought we were done.
Yeah, me too.
I thought level 2 was it for us.
I did not think we would survive this long.
Level 8 is crazy.
What's world record?
It might be.
We're closing in.
I've seen...
Toast got to level 15.
15?
Yeah.
He actually constructed the most try-hard group he could get.
Everyone was literally just trying their best.
Not like us where we try to sabotage each other.
And kill each other.
I think that's what makes it so incredible.
We were walking around.
You got me killed, bro.
I thought you killed yourself.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
Other people that they got him killed.
The reason I asked you where Doki was.
You guys were carrying that item.
And she fell into the pit.
And you didn't notice.
You just took the pit.
I need you to react to that clip.
It was so funny.
We were like, wait, where's Doki?
She fell into the pit.
You didn't even see it.
She just disappeared.
I was dying.
It was so funny.
And then you didn't even grab my head.
You didn't know you were dead.
Playing the game.
And then you lied to Cody and Matt.
It was like, I think she went that way.
Why would I just disappear?
Turn around.
I think she went that way and left.
It just got quiet.
It's gone and it's quiet.
It got real quiet.
It didn't speak for the rest of the round.
That's not what happened.
That's $8,000.
Is he going to do it?
He's doing his best.
He's looking around.
There's like three giant monsters running around.
I can't even see the map.
I don't know what there is left.
I wish I could see the map, but I guess that would be cheating.
Call her invisible woman the way she disappeared.
What am I?
Invisible?
Dude, those characters are so annoying.
Invisible woman is like, should I give them the count to four?
That's not a normal sentence.
Why are you doing that?
Her husband has one pit and she's like ride or die.
You're just jealous of Mr. Fantastic.
Who wouldn't be?
I was telling Tony my first floor was Mr. Fantastic.
He's fun.
He's just bad.
He's ass.
He's pretty terrible, but he's fun.
Oh, Cody, I got Celestial.
Good shit.
Did you get it solo?
Uh, yeah.
If you cheated, just say it, because I cheated.
Cody, you can't do that.
I cheated.
I don't care.
I just duo'd.
Duo is half cheating.
Cody six stacked.
I was there.
I was there on an alt account.
No, that's cheating.
Wait a second.
Wait, that's extra cheating.
We put super goblins on an alt account too.
Oh my god.
Cobus on an alt is illegal.
Cody is Celestial too.
Celestial too, baby.
That's crazy.
Okay, I guess I got to start cheating.
I got to start.
I was going to say ask J3, but he's been hard stuck Celestial.
So I don't think...
Why is he bringing the car for?
We don't know.
For real.
We'll never know.
We don't know the mind inside Void.
I can never understand the level of gamer he's at.
I thought I was a gamer.
Chat's like, let him cook.
Let him cook.
He is so dead.
He doesn't see it.
It's right there.
What is that?
We're having fun and Void has locked the fuck in.
Is that anxiety?
It was supposed to be just us four initially.
I don't think...
If we didn't have Void, we won't make it to level A.
I'm going to say it.
When he dies, we should all be really mad.
Strangely.
Irrationally angry at him for losing.
Oh, he's dead.
Oh my God.
He's trying to push it into the paint.
He's pulling so hard.
It's over.
There's no way.
He just forgot about him.
He's just clipping.
He's playing.
He's playing FGC right now.
He just backed up.
He's cheating.
He just walked through a wall.
Oh my God.
Look at that.
What kind of fighting game is he playing right now?
What kind of fighting game player is he?
He's cheating.
Which FGC is he?
Those are good foot C's.
What FGC is Void from?
He's a smash guy.
He's a smash guy?
Why can't you do that?
Back in Brawl.
See me in Brawl at Project M.
Oh my God.
You say that with Brawl throw in the call.
Which version of smash is he from?
Void did a smash 4 and ultimate.
Is that better or worse than yours?
Way worse.
Void is a shotgun guy.
They made the game way easier to play.
Can the shotgun guy shoot the ghoul monster thing?
Yeah.
There's like friendly fire.
What is he doing?
He's offering him a drink.
I don't know actually.
I don't remember if there is friendly fire.
I don't know.
I know that we can shoot him.
Oh by the way, that gun is a bait.
Do not use the gun.
That shit is ass.
Really?
Why?
I shot that ghost 3 times.
4 times dead on.
Didn't even flinch.
I was thinking you missed the first shot.
You gotta upgrade the gun first.
I saw you missed him.
I lasered that ghost.
Hit scan.
No, hit scan laser.
No.
Play the clip.
I will send it to everyone.
Also who shoots a ghost?
Why would you shoot that?
What the hell?
What is that?
He fell down the stairs.
And he tried to throw him in the pit.
What is that thing?
He is banking on shotgun guy kill.
For the final ones.
He is getting clipped guys.
He is trying to farm a clip right now.
Why did he fall down the stairs?
He is blind.
This is the common issue with him.
I am so serious.
He does not see the things that are in front of him.
But he is so good at literally everything else.
He is daredevil.
Why the fuck did we pick him?
I needed him to survive.
Right behind him.
Did you see it?
He actually went for the speed play.
And did not get punished.
How is he clipping through the map?
What is he doing man?
Imagine if Void had all the stamina.
And all the health.
Imagine if he was the Bidoof.
He would not be doing shit.
He would not be doing nothing.
I will just stay.
He is so mad.
This is huge.
I got to fucking carry these guys again.
Wait, that thing is usually worth like 6k.
Hey Treyarch.
Thanks for the raid.
We are playing repo.
I am doing really good.
Wait, did Coney die first?
No.
Dude, I did not get any bombs.
This is Coney smurfing right now.
He is dual boxing.
He has two pieces.
Is that on TikTok?
Coney and his TikTok reacts.
Right there.
They got the thing.
Oh my god.
There is no world.
That
shit sounded good as hell.
I know that shit felt good as hell.
That is the good shit.
The hardest hit of his life.
He is relaxed now.
He got sent to another dimension.
Shall we?
He hit that shit hard.
Oh my god.
He made it.
That is crazy.
That fucking sigh.
He is missing a head.
It is Matt's head.
It is your head.
Goodbye, Matt.
Goodbye.
Let's get back in there.
Holy shit.
Bored again.
We did it.
You were missing Matt.
It was a team effort.
We did it.
All of us together.
Push me.
He can't get me in the cart.
All right.
Let's go.
We did it, guys.
It is such a dire spot.
It would be very funny to push the cart into the lava.
I was thinking about it.
No, no, no.
Don't do it.
This will take me to 100k YouTube.
I will let it go.
We didn't ask Matt where he died.
A nun?
There it is.
And the gun guy.
Can the nun make noise so the gun guy shoots her?
Shut up.
The gun guy is right there.
Oh my God.
Is it Tony, Dad?
I am sorry.
I need a minute.
I'm just gonna pause for a minute.
Wait a minute...
Oh my god!
I can't, I can't!
She said don't pause!
I can't do this!
There's tears in my eyes!
I'm looking crazy!
My face looks like a loser.
I can't!
I'm trying not to laugh too loud.
I got snot everywhere.
I need help.
Fuck man.
Oh fuck.
Why did he make noise?
I can't, I can't.
I'm crying.
Holy fuck, I'm crying.
I'm gonna fucking die.
I can't.
I hope this is the level where we die.
I can't anymore.
Oh my god.
I actually can't.
God, that shit fucking killed me.
There's nothing here.
Why did it take me to the high ground?
Oh my god.
The hardest part was trying not to laugh too loud.
Because of the fucking...
The fucking shotgun.
God.
Don't get in.
Truly a real one.
You're still alive.
Maybe you guys are alive.
Hold on, I have to fix my face.
There's a broom nearby.
I saw.
It's like right here.
I wonder if there's anything extra here.
There's a cube.
10k cube.
I need help.
You need help?
10k cube.
Trying to reset myself after that day.
Teamwork makes the dream work.
I can go this way.
Oh, we're bringing Kony back.
Nice.
Okay, welcome back Kony.
Let's go.
We're finally all back.
We're all back together.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
We have one more.
We have one more to go.
I'm not kidding.
We might actually just be fucked if he comes in here.
Guys, we might be fucked.
Bye bye.
Look
what I found.
Oh my god.
There.
I won't forget you buddy.
Yeah, that was fucked up.
I won't bring you back.
That wasn't bad that time.
He was the one that warned us.
There's nothing up top.
There's nothing up there.
No, no, no.
I'm going to double check.
Woah.
No, he's alive and he's coming this way.
Sacrifice.
He was looking at you and then screaming.
So he would shoot you.
Is he
still there?
Is he still there?
Fear.
Lots and lots of fear.
I don't know how he died.
He just...
Showed up dead.
Oh god, he's still alive.
I'm scared.
I can't
do this one by one.
He has the cart.
I hope he finds his way here.
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Is it a child?
How much is in there?
Oh, you're here.
I'm still alive.
Okay.
There is a ghost on high ground.
Oh, he's here.
Is the child still there?
Oh no, not the baby.
Not the baby.
Okay.
Crap.
Not
the baby.
Gone.
Is baby not gone?
What is it?
Oh.
Anything up here?
Nothing.
Not one item.
I'm safe.
Okay.
I don't remember where the broom is.
I don't remember.
It was so long ago.
Thank you.
That was crazy.
I'm scared.
I'm scared again.
Scatter, scatter.
I
don't care.
I don't care.
Oh my god.
Are you okay?
No, I'm not.
I'm not okay.
Coney's dead too.
Coney died?
I got shot.
I don't even know where he was.
I got sniped.
That was unbelievable.
Coney, how the fuck did you die there when you said you were safe?
You were like...
No, I went that far.
When it was us two.
And then you were like, I think the baby's gone.
And then you fucking died.
I fell down.
Juice box, please.
After everything you fucking fell.
Me and my juice.
Juice, please.
He's ignoring it.
Yummy pear.
More for Coney.
Guys, we need HP.
We need HP.
I can't do this.
Health upgrade for Coney.
Alright, I'm hitting the button.
Yeah, go ahead.
Wait, there's an indestructible drone.
Should we have bought that?
That's really good.
We could have bought the indestructible drone.
It's really good.
It's okay, Coney got his...
It's okay, Coney got his juice box, guys.
I have my juice box.
I'm gonna be really strong.
He's gonna be the biggest boy out there.
I got my gummy worms.
Don't worry.
He got his vitamin C.
Guys, I think I deserve one of the health packs.
Bro, I am so strong.
Oh my god.
I am unbelievably powerful.
Holy shit.
What did you do, Coney?
What did you do?
I fell into the lava.
That's what happened.
Alright, I hit my power spike.
Yup, we're good to go.
I got my items.
We made it to level 9, guys.
That's actually kind of nice.
We had quite a run.
We had quite a first run.
I have a trophy.
Look, it's my oshi mark.
It's me.
Oh, this is the same map we were in earlier.
I feel like I aged like 50 years playing this one mode.
I'm aging as we play right now.
Maybe I should just die so I can relax.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
The fuck is this hellhole?
We can fall down, right?
Will we die?
Is it parkour?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if it's parkour.
Okay.
Guys, I'm so tired.
Guys, wait, let me...
Guys...
I think I gotta change real quick to something more appropriate after what Kony...
What Kony brought got me through.
Give me a sec.
I need to change real quick.
Where is it?
Don't wait.
Okay.
Oh hey, we already got the first one.
Oh.
I came here assuming this was extraction.
I think this is extraction.
Yeah, there it is.
Wait, what happened?
We were doing it, now we're not.
There you go.
Wait, what?
That's what I'm saying, what happened?
What did they do?
They crushed it.
No fucking way.
They crushed the cart.
I'm done.
I think they crushed the cart.
I think they...
Oh my god.
They crushed it.
I leave them alone for one...
for five minutes.
I... Kony, what happened?
Kony, what happened?
Kony, look into my eyes.
Kony, look into my eyes and tell me what happened.
Look into my eyes and tell me what happened.
That's really weird, that must be a glitch.
I don't know.
What happened, bro?
What happened?
Void is hearing things, so I just left him.
I don't think we're gonna make it, then.
We got it.
10k.
So something definitely got crushed, cause we had 19k earlier.
Yeah.
You got it?
Yeah, I got it.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, I'm gonna put this in the thing.
I don't want it destroying our items.
Alright, we got 10k.
Bro, this is a small map.
No, there's more.
There's more stuff.
There's downstairs.
Okay.
I wonder what got destroyed, guys.
I wonder.
Wait, it's 16k?
I thought we got 10k.
What?
Is it 6k in there?
We need 3k.
3k?
Yeah.
I'm so tired.
Wait, what?
Wait, how did he die?
I don't know.
I think he fell in the water.
There's water?
Yeah, where the vents are.
Oh, did he jump down?
It's safe down here.
You can jump down.
How did Matt die?
I'm so tired, guys.
I'm so very tired.
I had to do that one.
I had to do that twice.
Before he did it once, I had to do it twice.
I'll make it up to my team.
Check this out.
I don't like that sound.
Do you need help?
No.
Okay, you big strong man.
Okay.
Is there something in there?
What the fuck?
I'm not doing anything.
I'm putting it in the lava.
This is stupid.
I'm not even doing anything.
It's not going to go back into the vault.
Get the fuck out of here.
What?
Yo.
He got scared.
That was Doki.
She got scared.
She jumped down.
I got pushed.
That's what happened to me.
He picked up my seat.
There's an invisible man.
He grabbed me.
That's what happened to me.
I got grabbed.
There's Doki's head.
There's an invisible man?
Yes, I got kidnapped by an invisible man.
What?
I got stranger endangered.
Wait, Kony saw that.
Oh my god, Kony has no idea.
It's time for me to save the day.
I dropped Doki's head.
Hello?
Hi.
I thought there was no fall damage.
I fell from a high point with one HP and I died.
I'm about to fall off.
I think this is the run.
I don't think we're gonna make it, guys.
Don't do that.
But we always say that.
I think this is the run.
Kony only needs 2k.
Why are you saying he?
We have Void here.
Void was just talking about jumping off and killing himself right there.
So that's why.
I'm gonna use the bat.
There's invisible men and then there's pits.
They grabbed me and threw me in the pit.
What do I do?
I don't even know what you're saying.
I'm not gonna lie.
The invisible man grabbed me and threw me in the pit.
What do I do?
Disappear.
He hit me in.
I don't know where you are, but watch out.
Hey, what's up?
Watch out, I have money.
And he grabbed me, but not Kony.
Kony was infected.
He probably scared him.
No way.
They're 30 tens off.
What?
Give me $30.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'm in the room where Matt died.
They can't hear me.
They just said that Zoki and I are in the extraction room.
I'm fucking dead, brother.
Wait, is that $20?
Or $20,000?
Just $20,000, right?
That's weird.
We just need $0.35.
Kony has it.
It might be $20,000.
Cocktails, mixtures, ice.
Snacks, so... none.
Soda, sour, mixed, dry.
Lit, you can't deny.
Whatever you want, whatever you need.
Watch out, that's very fragile.
I'm back.
Is Kony doing it?
Is he doing it?
Kony hit his clutch moment.
He's singing the Bernice song.
I should not shake that around.
Oh, God.
He's doing it.
We're gonna be back.
Born again.
We're born again.
Thank you, Konymeister.
Wow, Kony, my savior.
Wow.
What could we do without you?
Kony, it turns out there is fall damage.
Do not fall from a high place on 1 HP.
Good to know.
I don't know where Brawl Pro is.
I still don't know where he's headed.
Oh, wait.
Oh, Brawl Pro was not picked up.
Where's the other extraction point?
I forgot.
Oh, it's over there.
We're born again.
Born again.
Anyone for tea?
Would anyone like some tea?
Tea?
Nobody liked my tea joke.
No, we did not.
I didn't.
I didn't like it.
Where do we go for more?
Oh, there's more stuff here.
I got 2.6 here.
And then...
There's another one here?
Yeah.
Nevermind.
Wait, what do you mean?
I found his head!
What happened to MatMan?
What the fuck?
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, how did he die?
I don't know how MatMan died.
What server?
What are you talking about?
Damn.
How did he die already?
I got a big boy box.
I'm ready.
I'm a big boy.
Carrying my big boy box.
And I'm gonna make it there.
Big boy time.
Big boy journey.
Oh my god.
Bigger boy.
The strongest boy up there.
Oh, I found the other extraction.
I'm so scared of the invisible man.
There's so many pits.
For this invisible man.
There's so many holes.
He could just pick one of us up.
And kill us.
Is that what he does?
Yeah, that's what happened to me.
He chucked me into the hole.
Don't touch the nose!
I'm behind you, behind you, behind you.
Wait, what happens when you touch the nose?
I think he blows up or something.
Ew, what is that?
Oh, that's the mouth thing.
Don't go in the pit, don't go in the pit.
Don't you dare come up here with me.
Don't you dare.
Fight your own battle.
He chose both of us.
We're both involved.
We were both involved in this fight.
No, no, no.
We're both in this together.
Oh my god, now he's chasing me.
He's camping.
Alright, there's a monkey doll.
We could get that.
No way.
I got the monkey doll.
Okay, I'm stuck.
I think he's like locked here.
Okay, he's good.
I got the monkey doll.
Ooh, ooh, ah, ah.
Okay, that's 2k.
Yeah, we need a little more.
Okay.
I don't think we're gonna get enough items by the way.
My chat is telling me that if I slam...
No, there's items on this place.
My chat is telling me if I grab this guy and I slam him up and down, I'll kill him.
Whoa.
Doll, doll, doll.
Oh my god, dude.
No, stop.
Sorry man, I had a long night.
Ew, you sound gross.
Dude, don't make fun of me.
Yeah, I've been working on it.
Ew.
Wait, can you control me?
Because when I was possessed, he tried to throw me into a pit.
No, no, I think you were doing it yourself.
Oh, I did that, okay.
Oh shit, the clown lady gets hurt.
Yeah.
Well, it sounded kind of handsome actually.
What's gonna fucking die?
No, he'll fight.
He'll fight, he'll win this.
Oh my god.
I can't read
it.
That's an awesome last word.
Oh my god.
And then he just fell.
Oh, that was good.
Wait, is that the invisible man?
That was really good.
What is this?
Yo, celebrate!
Yeah, let's go!
Celebration!
Alright.
I got his head.
No, I got it, I got it.
Alright, you push the cart.
No, no, that's already...
We just need a 2k.
Yeah, it's fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So what happened to that server, Kony?
The server.
Oh, I see, I see.
So nothing bad happened to it.
Yeah.
Oh, I see.
So how come like...
So like, how come it was at like 19k at one point and then went back to 1k?
Oh, we didn't order that much food.
What do you mean?
We got like some appetizers.
Just some appies?
Yeah, just some mozzies and a bloomin' onion.
Whoa!
How much was it in total?
Was it 1k?
I don't know what money's like in Canada.
You guys have loonies and toonies.
I don't think it went that high.
I don't know.
Alright, let's res our friends.
Does this work if I push it?
Yeah, just push it.
Because, you know, if something broke, that'd be very...
Yeah, something broke.
Oh!
Okay.
That was very scary.
This game is scary!
Is that everything?
Wait, you have health!
Cody, give me HP!
I'm bored, I'm dead!
You have 70 HP at least!
Cody is full HP!
Cody is almost full HP!
Heal me, heal me!
Cody, where did he go?
Where the fuck did this fucker go?
I have been turbo 1 HP for the past 7 levels.
You know what his HP is?
He never helps!
Alright.
Guess I'll take the cart over there.
Oh, I hope they live.
Hope he's alive.
I know this one was an extraction.
I have no idea they're alive.
I know Cody is fucking hiding somewhere.
Oh yeah, I know.
I was not going to be there for that.
I already got kidnapped once.
I learned my lesson.
Stranger danger.
There's a bonsai tree.
I don't think we're going to make it.
We broke a lot of stuff today.
We broke a lot of stuff.
I don't think we're going to find enough gas.
Whoa, we got split up.
That's weird.
Dude.
Okay, I didn't even touch it.
It fell from the sky.
Touched my neck right now.
You have 121 HP, Cody.
Give me at least 10.
Cody, don't make me.
Don't make me do it.
Give me my HP.
Give me my HP right now.
You know how much HP Cody has?
Do you know how much HP?
Yeah, I checked his streak.
It's like 180.
Cody, at least use your big boy streak for this fucking ice cube.
Cody.
Use your big boy streak right now.
I got a monkey.
We don't need the monkey.
This is 10k.
Monkey goes in the car.
Oh, this?
Worry not.
I will carry it.
With great ease.
Pony is strongest of all.
I'm scared.
What?
What was that scream?
Is this enough?
This is more than enough.
We don't know where Brofist Head is though, no?
It's fine, we just gotta...
What is happening here?
Who is this?
Get out of the corner.
What did you do, buddy?
Oh shit.
I got some HP.
You gave me HP back.
Wait, I feel better now.
I feel better now actually.
Wait.
I got some HP.
An actual checkmate situation.
All I needed was my friend.
How do you like it?
You're gonna die with that 180 HP.
You're gonna die with that HP and I know it.
Hold on, this is 10k.
What happened to Brofist Head?
I have no idea.
Why would you put it on the spear?
It's okay, it's okay.
Get out, get out.
Alright, turn around.
Alright.
Here you go.
What the fuck?
I'm healing.
There you go, even split.
Yoink.
Nice.
Alright, we have 4k in here.
We just need another...
What even happened to Brofist Head?
We don't know, nobody knows.
He just disappeared.
What did you do, boy?
Can't relate.
I'm talking about how Kony's a gigadad.
Weakass.
Nothing, dude.
Wait, it says there's something here.
Oh my god.
There's a spinning propane tank.
Don't worry about it, don't worry about it.
But it's so valuable, wait.
Oh, it's gonna kill us.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Is it empty?
Uh, it'll probably be lighter.
I didn't like that sound.
Oh, Kony, Kony!
Come over here!
Kony!
We need big boy Kony!
Yeah, there's a couple big things here.
Kony, there's another server for you to break.
That's my favorite thing to do.
Wait, there's something up top here.
What is it?
Oh, it's a box.
Jesus fucking Christ.
There's a diamond in here, too.
You wanna get the diamond?
Okay, yeah, I'll get the diamond.
Diamond's easier.
Let's get the box.
You wanna get the box?
The box is easier.
I think the box is easier.
Yeah, you're right.
There you go.
I mean, this was the only thing up there.
Yeah, it was, you're right.
That's the wrong way!
It is easier.
Look how easy this is.
Where's our fucking cart?
We can probably just bring it over.
That's true.
That's so true.
There's no way there's a server worth 20k that's about a big...
No way, right, Doki?
There's a server worth 7,500 that's about to burst.
7,000 dollar server.
Yo, our box is kinda late.
Yeah, our box...
It's gonna bring us all the way...
Okay, okay.
Coney, stop!
Hold it still.
Okay, we have...
Okay, we...
No, no, we have 4k in our money bag.
You're right.
I am actually power crept by Coney.
Wait, what happened to our cart?
What happened to our cart?
There's a girl with scissor hands taking her way downtown.
Oh my god.
Well, I mean, if the scissor lady comes here and fucks it up, then we are fucked.
Oh my god, Coney, no!
The box is blocking the pathway.
It's like a
diving attempt.
Yeah.
He did not do it, guys.
What happened to the 21k?
What happened?
What happened to it?
So what happened?
Oh, you're alive.
Yeah, so what happened to the 21k?
We thought you died.
Oh, okay.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
I'm leaving.
Scissor lady died and we're good.
I'll let them know.
Scissor lady's here.
There's two!
They're going the way we need to go.
Be gone.
Can you fucking crouch?
Don't make any noise.
Can you fucking crouch, please?
Please.
I will smash it.
Don't look at me.
Yes, there's B!
As fuck, yes!
You got caught.
Don't call me Liz!
I can't fucking see Liz.
I can't crouch.
I just see you get lit up.
Where did you die from, bro?
Dude, I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
I'll give it.
It was in the room with the vents.
In the swimming pool.
Cody used me as a fucking bait!
Cody, just go!
Cody's looking for him, but they're not close.
They are not close at all.
What the fuck is...
Wait.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Oh, he got your head.
Oh my god, my head is received.
Oh my god, we're coming back!
I'm coming back.
I'm back.
You fucking used me as bait, Cody!
I saw you!
You fucking used me as bait!
Let's go team, bro.
How are we still going?
How are we still doing this?
I am getting summoned.
I may have to go.
What are you getting summoned for, Void?
How could you leave, Void?
I'm getting a buff.
What's more important than us?
What's more important than us, Void?
Tell us right now.
What's more important?
Tell us, Void.
You have another run?
You're gonna cheat on us?
Wow, you're gonna cheat on us like that.
That means we gotta hurry up and get to the next one.
Alright, let's do it.
Void, no, no, no.
You're doing this last one, Void.
One more.
Last one, last one.
Last one.
Last one, Void.
Get over here.
I don't have the willpower.
Void, how could you say that?
Just AFK, just AFK.
Void, don't do AFK.
We have to do something.
He's saying he doesn't have the willpower to stay.
No, let's go.
I believe.
I need some help, y'all.
But I'm gonna go fast.
No, you don't.
I can't believe it.
You cheated.
I didn't think we'd have a four hour long run.
I can't believe it.
I don't think any of us fucking did.
You didn't think we would make it this far.
How could you say that?
And you're gonna leave the run like that?
You're gonna leave us?
I just think we're too good at video games.
I can't believe you would leave us like that.
Your other run's not gonna get as far as us, Void.
And you know it.
But it's already at level 17.
You're gonna feel so embarrassed when you die.
Yeah, but you weren't even part of that run, though.
You weren't actually part of it.
No, I was.
No, you weren't.
I was.
It's not a real run if they just stopped.
And kept going.
Look out!
Yeah, we stopped.
No, we've been doing it for a couple days.
Oh, but look at us.
We did it non-stop and we're at level 10.
Kony, we need you.
We need Big Boi.
I think I'm gonna go, guys.
We need Void!
I'm gonna go, guys.
No, Void!
Don't leave!
Oh,
wait.
He's dead.
Dude, why are there so many babies?
Just chuck them away!
There you go.
Oh my god, I got you.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Guys.
Maybe this is over.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
He's alive.
I can't believe Void just left us like that.
I can't believe he picked a different run over us.
We're so special!
We made it to level 10!
First try!
We are a very special group of people.
How could he?
I'm walking backwards.
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, there's like a bunch of stuff.
Guys, I don't think...
Okay, we should push this cart back.
I'm pushing it back.
What the fuck?
How did I even do that?
Okay, leave this here for now.
We leave this here for now.
Let's just push the cart back.
Matt fell into the pit.
Wait, Matt what?
Is he dead again?
There's no way.
No, we don't have room.
There's a big boy.
He's gonna destroy everything.
Kony's still over there.
What?
Oh my god.
That wasn't even me.
Behind you, Kony!
Okay.
This run is over.
Doki, no!
Doki!
I gave up.
The Roman Kony baited him into our cart.
I've given up.
No, what are you doing?
I gave up.
I said...
Wait, what?
Wow.
Great run.
Yeah, I win, Boyd.
What do you mean?
GG's, Boyd.
Yes, he is.
He is Soapy Doof, guys.
He is.
Oh my god.
I just got air dodged and fucking...
No!
Kony kills all Kony!
Challenger!
No!
We made him too strong!
We gotta put him down!
We have to put him down!
Get him!
Yes!
We got him!
Let's go!
Wait, wait, wait.
After everything we've done.
Boyd!
Wait, what the fuck?
How did...
It's always been us two, hasn't it?
Oh my god, I'm killing him!
Oh shit!
That has to be Doki.
Yippee!
It is always...
Doki Hot Armor.
I didn't know the stage got smaller.
How did you die, Boyd?
I don't even know!
I was not expecting a four hour run.
We went just easy!
Four hours?
It was more than that.
It was like five, almost.
Yeah, we lasted long.
I'm gonna go play more video games.
It was fun, guys.
Let me know if you guys play again.
We can play again later.
We are absolutely playing again.
Are we the best group you've ever had, Boyd?
This was really up there.
All of you guys played in the first one.
This is my second best run.
It could have been your first if someone didn't throw.
Cody!
No, Cody was too small.
Cody was stronger than you.
Bye, everybody!
Bye, everyone!
That was crazy.
I did not expect this.
This is actually not my first time playing Reaper.
I think this is my fourth time.
That was an insane fucking run today.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
But with Cody fucking...
Like...
That shit!
Oh, my God.
I was wheezing.
I was trying so hard...
not to like...
not to laugh.
So I had to wheeze because I didn't want to laugh.
Because I didn't want to die.
That was so fucking funny.
Oh, my God.
And then...
No, he lived the first shot.
He lived the first shot, but then he did it again.
I don't know why he did it again.
Oh, my God.
He juked it.
I saw him juked it.
It had like the perfect POV of it, too.
Anyway, I had a great time.
Before I got to rest now...
Before I go...
I do have something to show.
And that is the...
That is the...
Good Smile plushie.
Because the pre-orders are ending today!
So, if you want to have a Doki Bird...
Marketable Doki Bird plushie...
Please check out the links that I just...
posted.
Posted in chat.
Let me get the plushie so it looks like...
Basically looks like this.
Oh, shit.
Let me...
It looks like this.
So, yes, pre-orders for it is ending today.
Last day of pre-order, guys.
The more pre-orders we get, the more opportunities we can get...
in the future with Good Smile.
So, yes, pre-order now!
Before I go.
Pre-order, pre-order.
It helps a lot.
In regards to supporting the stream...
And supporting this channel.
And supporting for more merch in the future.
But, yes!
What?
Oh my god.
I cannot expect this run to go...
4 hours.
That was fucking crazy.
I did not...
I thought we were going to...
Go to level 3 or something.
But the fact that we went to level 10...
Is absolutely insane.
But I had a lot of fun.
I always have a lot of fun playing with Team Brawl Pro.
Um...
Lots of really funny moments.
I feel like I aged like 50 years when I was left alone.
And I had to clutch it.
I literally did not talk for like...
I think like 10 to 15 minutes.
Because I knew the moment I say anything...
I fucking die.
I just...
I knew I was going to fucking die.
I...
I said it.
My heart was beating during the...
My heart was beating so fast.
Um...
When I had to bring the fucking broom down the staircase.
Because I was like...
If I lose 2 more K.
I would not make enough money for it.
It was so scary.
But anyway.
I had a great time.
I'm going to call it here now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!